a TV cast of The Office reunited for a
wedding surprise I love this because
we're big office fans in my house it
happened during the newest episode of
John Krasinski's YouTube show some good
news Krasinski surprised a Maryland
couple by officiating at their virtual
wedding then he wrapped up the ceremony
by recreating a funny wedding scene from
the office take a look so well we can't
play this song unless you let me invite
some of my family to the party ladies
and gentlemen the cast of The Office the
cast members taking part in the wedding
dance included Steve Carell Rainn Wilson
Mindy Kaling and Ed Helms he went
through all this because the couple had
actually their proposal had mimicked Jim
and Pam's proposal in the office Jim
played of course by Krasinski so he
brought the parents in on zoom too he
brought their best friends in and they
brought everybody from the office in and
played that that great of course Chris
Brown forever song which was which plays
a pivotal part in the scene in season
six so it was a great moment great to
see them all together again yeah it was
it was John Krasinski just keeps topping
himself why cuz he's such a nice guy I
always look forward to those episodes